just like with the prequels I will bring
balance look before we get into this
you've got to know some things like you
I love Star Wars no I'm not a fan of the
prequels yes I grew up watching the
original trilogy before the Phantom
Menace came out in 1999 I have very fond
memories of sitting down with my family
to watch a VHS recording of all three
films recorded to one tape that was my
first exposure to Star Wars that's where
I fell in love with these movies the
original trilogy opened my mind to more
than just a galaxy far far away it had a
huge hand in introducing me to limitless
storytelling
literally anything I could imagine I
could create whether that was through
making films drawing acting or writing
stories Star Wars was a big part of my
formative years that cultivated my
creativity I owe the original trilogy a
lot for that so why am I doing this list
well if you've been following me for any
length of time you know that I can
really like to challenge myself with
these countdowns I don't always make
worse lists for every video I do a best
one on but in this case I thought it was
appropriate there is some content out
there objectively looking at the
negative aspects of the original trilogy
but not a ton since this is still Star
Wars month I wanted to see if I could
make a list of worst moments from these
three films and no I will not be taking
the easy way out and counting the
unpopular special edition changes this
list is going to
the issues that existed before Lucas
went in and added new effects while also
altering key scenes this is one of the
more difficult countdowns I've had to
put together but to get to the best
moments next week we got to get through
the worst this week
oh let's get ready to nitpick these are
the top 5 worst Star Wars original
trilogy moments how they're to say
number 5 governor talk I should expect
it to find you holding Vader's leash I
recognized your foul stench when I was
brought on board I'm focusing on Leia's
accent here this one is definitely a
miniscule detail and the grand scheme of
things but it still sticks out to me
when we watching any help from episode 4
a new hope grand moff tarkin brings in
princess leia to discover where the
rebel base is located things get much
more serious when the Death Star is
revealed to be in striking range of
Leia's home planet Alderaan all
throughout this scene Leia is speaking
with a sort of half-hearted English
accent it fades in and out no it is
peaceful we have no weapons you can do
without another target a business
totally target and doesn't ever show up
again don't get me wrong the rest of
this scene is great it's the first time
we get to hear you may fire when ready
and it's a pivotal moment in the first
film just why is she talking like that
the more you tighten your grip talk the
more star systems will skip to the other
fingers promotion is actually pretty
good it's not really a bad performance
and some interviews Carrie Fisher
explained that her lines there could not
have been done in an American accent I'm
surprised you've had the courage to take
the responsibility also yeah I guess I
can kind of see your point in any case
this little detail can pull me out of
the scene from time to time told you I
was gonna be nitpicky number four well I
guess you don't know everything about
women yet
[Music]
because of Game of Thrones fictional
twincest is popular again but let's not
forget where it all started from episode
5 The Empire Strikes Back
Luke has just recovered from a wampa
attack and regroups with his friends who
are having a pre lovers core to make Han
jealous Leia kisses Luke on the lips for
at least like three full seconds what
makes this a little worse is that the
extended scene plays up their romance
even more
that doesn't count as it's not in the
movie but it helps give us a clearer
picture of where they might have been
going with these to the peck in a new
hope was one thing but it seemed like
the original plan was to build up the
friendship between Haim Luke and Leia as
more of a love triangle
thus in retrospect this scene is more
than a little awkward at the time though
we didn't know Luke and Leia were
brother and sister so it's not like it
affected the quality of Empire
transition number three
[Music]
this moment is unpopular with a lot of
people from Episode six return to the
Jedi the gang is attempting to escape
Jabba the Hutt's palace where Boba Fett
has been since dropping off the
Carbonite frozen Han Solo he tries to
attack as Solo accidentally strikes him
sending Bubba Fett down into the Sarlacc
pit and his death most of us can't agree
that this was pretty lame Boba Fett was
definitely a fan favorite
the mysterious bounty hunter captured
the attention of Star Wars fans and the
Empire Strikes Back and built a pretty
strong following that made it all the
more disappointing when this previously
threatening character died like a cheap
cartoon villain a letdown for sure but
his death here hasn't affected his
popularity but what Fett continues to be
one of the more appreciated underused
Star Wars characters at least he didn't
get his head cut off like his clone dad
number two
[Music]
I'm gonna be honest I don't hate the
Ewoks but there's a reason they're on
the list from Episode six Return of the
Jedi our heroes have been captured by
the Ewoks while c-3po is looked at by
these little critters as a guy he tries
to make the Ewoks release his friends
but it's more difficult than Luke and
Han think this scene just feels off the
tone to the acting especially from
Harrison Ford seems strange What did he
say
somehow I got the feeling that didn't
help us very much
well I don't despise the Ewoks they're
definitely a low point in the original
trilogy they sort of represent the
trade-off of the dark and serious tone
that Empire Strikes Back did so well
with the less serious and sometimes
straight-up goofy attitude of Return of
the Jedi this scene I think is them at
their worst and while this is fine for
little kids to an adult or even older
kids this can be kind of grating when
we're expecting the more grave
storylines to wrap up in the same movie
but hey at least we get to hear you bub
at the end oh they took that out great
and the number one worst Star Wars
original trilogy moment is my sister has
it
it's you
and now
somehow I've always known this scene
itself isn't all that bad
it's the idea behind it that I'm not a
fan of from Episode six Return of the
Jedi Luke reveals to Leia that she is
his sister the twins share a moment
before Luke leaves to confront Vader
after which Han joins Leia as she is
both confused and distraught by this
news Leia and Luke being siblings wasn't
always the plan while it's always been
accepted by the audience it has been
questioned in recent years Luke having a
sister was definitely a thing but Leia
being that sister wasn't decided until
Return of the Jedi as seen earlier in
this list it's pretty damn clear that
these two weren't supposed to be related
as of the release of the Empire Strikes
Back the original idea of Luke's sister
debuting in Episode six actually sounds
better than it conveniently turning out
to be Leia it made those quasi romantic
moments between the two in the previous
films a little creepy all in all these
moments don't really affect my enjoyment
of the original trilogy if anything the
number one moment had me thinking of the
possibilities of what could have been
and that makes the lore of the making of
Star Wars even more interesting over on
my personal channel I have a review up
of the last Jedi and have been reviewing
season 4 of Star Wars rebels so check it
out for more Star Wars content I want to
hear what you guys think what is your
least favorite Star Wars original
trilogy moment what do you want me to
cover next on the show leave a comment
and let me know to keep in touch like my
Facebook page facebook.com slash awesome
walter b or follow along on twitter to
take part in more polls about what may
be covered in the future come back next
week is I try to make this up to you
guys after I go to a hospital
[Music]
you